vous avez sûrement remarqué que le prix
du beurre de la margarine et du grand
général à Bondy Johan nous explique
pourquoi
que vous soyez plutôt bas ou plutôt
margarine vous invite très certainement
remarqué l'augmentation du prix du gras
dans la dernière année
ça peut dépendre des types de beurre etc
mais c'est de l'ordre de 20%
et presque le double du côté de la
margarine je pense autour de 40 45% sur
les étagères en 5 ans les hausses sont
de près de 50% pour le bar et plus de
70% pour la margarine comment expliquer
de telles augmentations prenons d'abord
le beurre dans l'ingrédient principal et
le lait on ajoute environ deux points 2
milliards de litres de lait par année
qui est transformé dans 19 de nos usines
l'usine Lactalis de Winchester en
Ontario
fabricantia
les prix sont réglementés par la
Commission canadienne du lait alors dans
la dernière année il y a eu trois
augmentations successives du prix du
lait
une augmentation d'un peu plus de 13% en
un an
le prix des eaux de nos autres coûts
également ont augmenté alors si on pense
à la distribution
l'anthroposage l'énergie la main-d'œuvre
etc ces couleurs nous ont été refilés
comme transformateur
des prix plus élevés mais également
moins de promotion et le consommateur en
étant parti responsable les
consommateurs aiment des produits plus
gras alors le ce qui est plus l'ennemi
que le grand et donc des laits à plus
forte teneur en matière grasse des yogos
plus riches en matière grasse des
fromages de la crème glacée etc des
produits plus gras qui nécessitent donc
plus de crème alors en ayant moins de
crème disponibles on fait moins de barre
moins d'inventaires et en bout de ligne
ben il se fait moins de promotion donc
la consommateur il compare peut-être au
bord qui achetaient il y a 2 3 4 ans à
2,99 ou à deux à trois et 49 ce qui est
plus possible de trouver aujourd'hui
même en vente
un constat que nous avons voulu vérifier
nous avons donc épluché des circulaires
publiées au Québec depuis le 1er janvier
2020 résultat le beurre ou la margarine
était en promotion pendant 36 semaines
en 2020 26 en 2021 21 semaines en 2022
il n'y a eu que quatre promotions
pendant le premier trimestre de cette
année et oubliez le bar à deux dollars
99 comme en 2020 aujourd'hui au rabais
il se vend 4 dollars 44
[Musique]
qui est prêt à être envoyé sur le côté
production
la margarine quand elle est composée à
80% d'huile végétale en ce moment
j'imagine qu'on doit être au-dessus de
500 000 de 2000 millions de livres de
végétal une huile dont le prix a
beaucoup augmenté au cours des derniers
mois l'huile non raffinée a augmenté de
300% au moins
le prix de l'huile végétale est fixé par
la Bourse de Chicago il fluctue en
fonction du coût des céréales de la
demande de la météo ou encore de la
géopolitique mais ce n'est pas tout le
transport certainement quintuplé si
c'est pas plus surtout le transport
maritime les marges des raffineurs dans
notre contexte les majorationnaires ont
augmenté à peu près 5 à 6 fois donc au
final l'augmentation a été quand même
salée de nos coûts pour pour les huiles
végétales
une augmentation trop salée pour que le
consommateur l'absorbe à lui seul
solution produire la margarine à perte
le prix vendeur c'est un produit qui est
dans le rouge depuis longtemps quand
même est-ce qu'il va faire la plus
grande peur de nos ventes ça va être les
marques maison donc les marques des
épiciers qu'on va vendre au Canada mais
aussi aux États-Unis puis en Amérique du
Sud ou partout dans le monde
[Musique]
les transformateurs ne sont pas les
seuls à devoir composer avec ces hausses
de prix c'est aussi le cas des
fabricants qui utilisent ces matières
grasses en grandes quantités
du Mas de Québec fabrique croissant
vol-au-vent et autres pâte feuilletées
c'est la matière qui coûte le plus cher
dans la fabrication de la pâte
feuilletée
des matières grasses qui se payent plus
cher ici aussi
dans les deux trois dernières années qui
ont augmenté en 25 et 50% selon la
composition du gras pas question pour
autant de faire des compromis sur la
qualité
de fournir d'absorber ces hausses là
mais nous on veut un bon feuilletage
dans l'eau croissants mais maintenir
cette qualité à un coût malheureusement
les augmentations de prix se font sentir
tout au long de la chaîne de production
mais en bout de ligne c'est le
détaillant qui fixe les prix détaillant
lui il a pas le choix d'augmenter le
prix et évidemment c'est eux qui
établissent le prix qu'on voit sur les
tablettes c'est pas nous ne sommes pas
des bras de fer qu'on peut engager parce
que le rapport de force n'est pas
de notre côté
et si les dernières années ont été très
difficiles pour l'industrie la situation
semble s'améliorer en 2023 je dirais
dans la dernière année il y a eu une
légère contraction on est revenu
probablement au niveau qu'on était
précovite ensemble sentir que c'est que
c'est réglé actuellement les prix sont
stables autant du côté de l'huile de la
margarine shopping et du beurre c'est ça
qu'on sent même des petites baisses qui
ont donc j'ose croire que on va être
capable d'avoir des meilleurs prix dans
le courant de l'année 2023
de la margarine et de l'huile risque de
baisser prochainement pourrait-on alors
espérer que tous les produits
transformés qui ont du gras dans leur
liste d'ingrédients diminue leur prix on
peut rêver